happy 2022 everyone it's so good to be
back
today we're talking about starting your
year with free cloud education more
inclusive hybrid meetings and the eight
mega trends that we're looking at to
improve cloud security and cloud
adoption
i'm jenny brown and welcome to this week
in cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
if one of your resolutions was to grow
your cloud skills you're in luck
we've compiled a list of free learning
opportunities for you to kick off your
year with education
from free access to cloud skills boost
to half day trainings on cloud
fundamentals go to the blog for the full
list dates and to sign up
as we enter 2022 it's clear that
adjusting to ambiguity and remote work
is critical to success
google meets spent much of 2021 adding
features and functionality to workspace
to support a hybrid team from
backgrounds to noise cancellation
google also spent much of last year
developing our own best practices as a
team for making hybrid meetings as
inclusive as possible
to further improve that hybrid work
experience
check out the blog for more details on
how to make the most of your meetings
at google cloud we prioritize security
by design and work continuously to
deliver secure products and customer
controls
additionally we take advantage of
industry mega trends that increase cloud
security further outpacing the security
of on-prem infrastructure
i.t decision makers should pay close
attention to these mega trends because
they're not just transient issues to be
ignored once 2023 rolls around
they guide the development of cloud
security and technology and will
continue to do so for the foreseeable
future
head to the blog for the full list and a
deep dive
if you want to read more about any of
these announcements or see a full list
check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see it in the cloud